you know what let's kick it off with the
right way with shohei ohtani on the hill
making his 11th start which by the way
is a new career high taking on these
first place giants get 2-2
under the swing the slider that time and
down goes belt that's a big one yeah
that's an important one especially you
still have options two two three two you
have to pretty much go after with a
fastball this is a slider with a real
good late tilt to it showie otani with a
big strikeout
show hey driven toward right field into
the glove of randhifo hit hard but it's
a now there's a look at the giant
starter kevin gausman 14 starts this
year having a great year change up
slider loves the fastball in the
splitter there it is there's the
splitter for the strikeout
splitter
inning over
donovan solano is his foe the count is
one and two and he waves at a slider
down and away solano will strike out
victim starting to get a lot more
strikeouts with his slider of late
got a commitment went back to the slider
stays stubborn
i think he's still in shock how much
that slider broke
i don't blame him he's still looking
where's that split
here's the 3-2
and he got him looking slider struck him
out ohtani strikes out the side
and out of the reach
of anthony rendon who is at the
shortstop position
and dickerson is two for two
hit hard iglesias races to the bag and
he wins that race and he's racing to the
dugout
and he flips it over the high screen
it's a souvenir
this game's fun darn it all kinds of fun
struck him out
nasty
yeah that one was nasty usually that
splitter will drop straight down but if
you watch that again it goes down and
away
two-two pitch ohtani strikes out
swinging crossman being very stubborn
with that splitter he's got five
strikeouts now
through the first 11 hitters of the game
mike kastremski is popped to short and
ground to the first yastremski high
drive to right field and the giants are
on the board it is one to nothing tenth
home run of the year for yaz the power
bat has come to life for yashremski and
that was a bomb well it's one thing the
giants have done all year they've been
clutch at the right times and
ohtani on one two got in fastball
instead of the split he went with the
express upstairs
huge pitch
split-fingered fastball kicks away
suzuki turns it into and out what a job
by shohei ohtani even though he gave up
the run
limited damage bringing the heat a
couple of strikeouts for luis
switch hitter batting left-handed
fall high fly ball right field still
carrying still carrying
well you talk about flying around the
bases red heapho he said you know what i
don't need to be on base i need to run
around the bases and tie it up
over the top of a split finger fast
while ohtani will go back to work with
the tie game
the 3-2 from ohtani
got him
i love that reaction mike myers 4-6-4
e-r-a in his 35th appearance of the year
tuchman goes down on strikes it's the
1-2
that's an inning my goodness if that
doesn't send a message to your dugout
1-1 our score
chopper crawford the hurried throw
in time
close play
and
just beautifully done by crawford
good pitch strikeout number nine
for gorsman
blazing fastball out over the plate that
was an electric pitch close to
unhittable 97 a little bit off the
corner great spot
shot the hole
and efo fires toward third pretty big
arm it slips by rendon
anthony's throw to the play in time
oh baby anxious moments there
one one our score still with an
aggressive throw by rennhippo here's
what happened i mean
did a nice job of charging that baseball
got behind the baseball wall and a good
throw but it looks like it hits belt the
back of the leg and gets away from
anthony rodon who wisely gets up and
makes a good throw to the plate belts
clearly was injured going around again
towards home plate hopefully he'll be
okay he's been really really good iselle
iglesias your turn now work of late has
been nothing short of heroic
[Applause]
inside corner frozen with a changeup
got it wow
that's the kind of inning that creates
momentum that's the kind of inning that
could create a walk-off
one-two pitch
here it is
left center field and duggar
we're heading
into extra innings
[Applause]
gets the put out
littell to rough and back to the towel
that got a piece of
now straight off the mask
springs he has
in the mass tried to absorb some of that
but he's straight back at him
yeah he's going to have to come in the
game taylor ward is the catcher
most importantly we want kurt suzuki to
be okay
solano at second base he's the automatic
runner and duggar at the plate
that ball is ripped into right field for
a base hit
solano coming around duggar heading for
second here comes the throne the relay
not in time
and the giants have gone ahead two to
one
stephen duggar with a double you see
angels get the tying runner over to
third with one out bottom of the 12th
here's the next pitch that's a shot and
hits off the pitcher and it carrums away
from the shortstop and coming in and
scoring for the angels will be iglesias
so laguaris gets an infield hit and the
ball game is tied quickly at two
roller right side they'll come home with
at the time
incredible
should provide some drama here's russ
throw to the plate let's watch the slide
in the tag
i think he's out
[Music]
although they have to decide when was
the tag applied exactly it's hard to see
right there when does buster
tag the pant leg of lagarus
brian addison saw that foot come across
a plate i think that's why i called him
safe
out he is out at the plate this game is
not over
faces loaded for crawford 3-1 pitch is
way inside ball four
will come in to score giants back ahead
three to two
on the bases loaded walk after the
intentional walk claudio has walked two
more in a row and joe madden's coming
out to make a pitching change
and that one gets away
and the run will score
huge
the giants have parlayed a free base
runner
three walks
and a wild pitch into two runs in this
inning duggar got the big hit in the
12th inning to put the giants ahead but
oh not to throw him out and
there's no play to be made one runner's
in and crawford just kept on coming
two-run score on the infield hit by
duggar
six to two giants
so here's chalkman he is due
that ball is smoked
right center field adios
when you do you do
a three-run homer for tortman
the giants have scored seven runs
on two hits in this inning
that's a nice job getting in front
making that play run scores it's 9-3
his delivery puts him right back into
the shadows
there's a swing a line drive to
shortstop caught by brandon crawford
reaching to his backhand side knee-high
and that puts it into it and the giants
sweep this series with a rather
remarkable and zany game